at this launch event a meeting between
two cultures with a common purpose
south korean ministers and officials on
one side
on the other young defectors from north
korea wanting to make their mark in
business
jessie kim came to south korea eight
years ago bringing with her a lifelong
love of food which she is turning into a
successful online business promoting
north korean cuisine
as a child i was fascinated by the
ingredients the smell and
characteristics of food and always
prepared meals for the whole family in
my hometown
her home is near to mount bectu
considered by north korea's leadership
to possess special significance and
straddling the chinese border through
which most defectors escape to the south
is north korea's heavily fortified
border with south korea much harder to
cross and the scene of dramatic attempts
such as this defection by a soldier in
2017 amid a hail of bullets once they
get out of north korea many defectors
find that is only the start of their
troubles the bigger challenge is
adapting to south korea's much freer
lifestyle and fast-paced economy
completely unlike anything they've been
used to jessie kim has made that
transition successfully
i think for all young people business is
difficult i don't think i found it any
harder or easier as a north korean
defector
but many defectors struggle with some
even returning to the north
this scheme is aimed to help them with
business startups with the wider goal of
closer integration between north and
south
i am convinced this is an opportunity
for people like you and future
generations to dream big and initiate
change across the korean peninsula
startup businesses that produce goods
and services for both the north and the
south can help reduce the psychological
distance between the two koreas
inter-korean relations currently in a
deep freeze even small initiatives it
seems keep alive the hope of closer ties
one day rob mcbride al jazeera seoul